hi I am eager bug sri i am with Wolfram
research and my talk will be about the
channel framework and the way how you
can talk from any HTTP enabled device to
your Wolfram language session
so and you saw my hands are here I did
not type that hello that was a
preliminary thing to execute so as soon
as someone on their computer types in
anything into that line on their
computer my computer will receive it and
everyone who subscribed to the channel
which is called the most milliner
everyone will receive that pillow hey
also will do alright so this is a
preliminary how does it work and in this
talk will briefly say explain how it
works we talked a little bit about
publish-subscribe model which we use
orbitz we'll see when we need channel
and when we don't need channels and we
get to know some fun applications in not
in great many details but liberal will
bro through so basically what is channel
framework the channel framework allows
any HTTP enable the device talk to your
Mathematica session and that is very
powerful you probably understand it any
HTTP enabled device can now talk to your
mathematical session and that of course
includes Mathematica itself and many
other applications virtually anything
now can talk HTTP and therefore anything
can now talk to you Mathematica session
so how it works you execute a channel
listener channel listen command you give
a name of the channel that you want to
listen on you do you will enter some
function that you need that you want to
execute when a message arrives or you
can drop that part and execute a default
listener that is also fine and you give
permissions
in this case I gave public anyone as
soon as I executed anyone can send
commands to that speak channel and my
vote from language session will speak
the command and I also set up listener
dynamic here so as soon as message
arrives it will not only speak but it
will also update the listener so now I
cooked up if you command in this case
it's curl so i am going to my terminal
session I am pasting these I'm not sure
you heard this have you okay so people
in the first row can actually see the
can actually hear that but my
Mathematica actually spoke the command
and we see that param 123 is also
updated in my dynamic I executed this
curl on my machine but actually this
curl command can be executed anyway on
the internet and your Mathematica
session will receive this message
another example I built up a URL I am
going to my web browser and I just paste
that URL here did you hear that alright
so we are in business now ok it executes
it again never mind that so and of
course Oh vote from language itself can
do HTTP requests and you can do URL
fetch with that the same URL or in
mathematica client it can be even made
more convenient you just say channels
and because I want this to be executed
on anyone anyone's machine
did not say just speak I said vote from
ID my ball from ID colon speak and that
will be fully qualified name of the
channel so if I was spoken the speaking
between myself I would not need this
wall from idea if you want other users
to talk to you you would say vote from
ID colon I do not do that I don't know
what is helping him ok so now I did that
and it's executed it received and on the
mathematical side we can see that's
amazing / am did someone centered aha
alright okay so that guy spoiled the
nice stable way out here if if you
didn't do that it the data set would be
a nice table but because it's a public
channel that actually brings up a good
point if there is a public channel you
should always think very carefully of
what you want to execute on that channel
and basically you do not ever execute
any Wolfram language command on a public
channel because you can fry you her disk
or exactly exactly but in this case is
harmless because it just speaks the
message but now i will remove channel
listener before he sends some another
command
right right it's in several places so
the command to send via URL is in
channel send documentation that will
give you that part let me highlight it
that operation equals to send and then
goes your URL encoded message but the
part of the URL itself that one is this
listener URL this will give you the
exact URL to send you data to ok now
what I did here either I removed that
channel listener and I did this a
because as a public channel that they
don't want anybody else like Bob doing
things on my machine but basically it's
a common hygiene it can live there the
channel listener Kelly is there but you
don't want hundreds of channel listeners
hanging around and doing things that you
don't want it so just after you done
with the channel do this remove channel
listener if you forget nothing bad will
happen channels will time out
automatically so what is happening here
don't make photos of this page I i I'm
I'm half joking because the architecture
is experimental but there will be
several aspects that are set in stone
and will not change and the basic is
that there are clients this clients
which is coral browsers devices in this
case I have an icon of icon of Arduino
Yoon and of course mathematica clients
those clients will send messages there
are other clients like multiple Volvo
from Berlin recession which listens on
this
all those channel and there is a server
in the middle and don't worry about that
particular part because they also will
always be will be a server which
connects all these devices and services
so basically what we have done is we
abstracted away all minor details of how
do you talk to this particular device
how this receiver receives the function
there is completely abstract way the
clients know only how to talk to the
server which is a regular HTTP request
for sending and for receiving data so
that part gives you actually a lot of
flexibility you can have one-to-one
many-to-many one too many many to one in
any combination so our chat that we saw
at the very beginning our toys yet was
that part is many too many as soon as
you type that command it will go to you
and to anyone else listen in on that
channel that was the many to many
examples of many too many connections so
you don't always need channels if you
just want Mathematica to execute some
mathematical language expression and get
the result back you do not need the
channel framework view you would use API
function form function mail receiver
function and plenty of other tools to
get your code executed in Mathematica
you don't hit the channel framework if
you want to store data permanently you
would use cloud object you will you will
use data drop API again you do not need
a channel framework for that although
channel framework can do all these
things too it can save data it receives
in a data being it can go to save data
in a cloud object but if you only need
that part only saving or executing
functions you do not need a channel
framework now when do you need if you
want your particular mathematica session
to receive data and display them for
example or execute a command in your
particular mathematical session then you
would be happy to use that channel
framework because it will give you
exactly as that and if for example I
won't execute something on Bob's machine
and he gives me permission to do that
then I can execute no he won't ok i will
ask somebody else that lexi is usually
more cooperative so we you can execute
the command on any other machine that
gives you permission that is also where
the channel framework is very useful now
one application obvious application for
that is use your vote from session for
the dashboards for remote data so what
I'm doing now I have created started to
listen on a channel named points and now
I am going to my ok great to my cloud
account and I do a command which will
send the data every second intimate
America is just a run scheduled task so
what is happening is that my cloud
account sends data to my ball from
language session and you see here my
ball from language session updates
automatically so basically in this case
it's run scheduled task interval from
language session but it can be device it
can be anything that you want and it
will work exactly the same way so I am
stopping this nonsense and I'm executing
next command setting up a listener in
that session but we will use that
listener
in a little while okay so now we create
new listener we start listening on a
channel named local and as you see there
is no messages here in oil that listener
so now we will send a command and you
saw that this dynamic updated right so
what has happened my local session the
this session send data to my cloud
account my cloud account executed that
my command automatically and that was
the listener I set up just a few minutes
ago that part in in the cloud there was
a listener that that I set up so that
listener executed a message that I
received that it received and sent bait
send data back to the address that we
used that in in reply to field so what
has happened is that my local computer
communicated with the cloud God data
executed there and received the data
back and just so that you know that I am
NOT cheating the separation system is
Mac and it has different machine ID and
unix is our cloud account which runs on
unix okay and of course this thing can
be used for many different exciting
projects for example you probably all
heard about city at home so if you think
of any globally interested projects that
can be executed using vote from language
talk to us we will help you to set it up
and if people will be willing to lend
their vote from language
power to your to your task you will get
that city at home set up in almost no
time so and we can do it very securely
that is a separate issue you can call
them that okay great I have no idea
what's going on okay something's missing
okay let's see if I can go without that
okay so another example is to talk to
from devices to your mathematical
session as we already discussed if you
are interested in details go to Ian
Johnson talk on Friday he will be
talking about arduino not necessarily
you know but other are other arduino
shields that will talk to your
Mathematica session another example is
cheered we saw my little demo toy it's
not full blown yet but the code is
provided you can do any any elaborate
things that you want with that and the
code isn't your mathematical in the
version 11 now you can send that we call
it will vote from instant messages
between two machines that example is
detailed in the documentation for
channel listen go look it up if you are
interested in you can see how you can
send messages back and forth and these
messages can include any mathematical
expression or entire mathematical
notebooks so you can send you can do
group chat and send the exchange
notebooks and in fact there is a much
bigger Chet framework is being developed
and today people who will be using who
participated in that competition tonight
hopefully we'll be using that more
sophisticated
yep to than I'm describing here now you
can integrate with the ifft or other
cloud services and if you're interested
in that there is a trip very you
interest in them or running downstairs
in the connectivity booth go and see it
you will see how it works you can
connect that you can use the same thing
in mail receiver function on any API
function so you probably know how to use
API function already so if you want to
know who executed a command in your
public API function and you will see
locally for example list of users as
they execute your commands you can just
add channel send to your API function
and your math America session will life
update you on anyone using your API
function in the cloud it is very easy
that examples example is also in the
documentation I am NOT going to Jesus
okay I'm right enough time let's see if
the second well okay now you eat I don't
have too much time to experiment okay
okay sorry about that let me try to
launch this again mathematica is very
strict apparently about licensing I i
cannot hear you okay all right okay so I
i if you give me a couple of minutes let
me
okay does not quite work I you have to
somehow remember what the hell I was
supposed to talk about okay so we saw
how to run that okay other examples you
can use you can communicate with the
server lyst applications like for
example amazon lambda there is an
example it sure is also in the
documentation where you put things into
your s3 example and as soon as you
images for example drop into your budget
yo Mathematica will receive and
automatically update your your images
that is another example right no you
have my notebook all right okay we don't
we don't have time for that ok so I'm
almost done just to sum up any device
that can talk HTTP can talk to your
mathematical session right now the
functions that you define in the channel
listener or on the channel in the
definition of the channel can be
anything that you want there is a
powerful permission mechanism there are
different areas you can give different
people or different groups of people
execute permission right permission read
permission everything is taken care of
it is safe to evaluate not ability is
safe to receive a code in your session
because your channel will wrap it in
hold all complete and there are the
disabled for margin feature that will
come make the code camp
inert so it is safe to receive data on a
public channel that is taken care of but
if you receive data on a public channel
and apply release hold on it you are
fried so so don't don't ever evaluate
anything on a public channel look at it
first so that part is a castle has
already been worked out and if you have
more questions after the talk I will be
in the connectivity booth downstairs so
friday 10 to 12 you are very welcome to
come and talk and i will demo everything
in much more in much greater detail
please questions thank
[Applause]